whatever we're doing is we have to be
clear about how Sony you Game Pass and
how they are changing their structure to
mimic Xboxes that is the fact this is
from their own mouth this is no one
lying in court there's no one under
duress this is how they feel so this was
their private thoughts yes this is pill
oh so they was pillow talking yeah they
was laying down with Shorty and shorty
leaked them leak the information out oh
I like this so that that's the thing I
just wanted to clarify because again
again their own words industry stft the
leap frog active provides incredible
strategy against these livs of value
across live service games scal and
mobile PC front and the last thing that
I keep telling people because
everybody's like oh you know the the the
Call of Duty aspect we get it